yo it's 6 a.m catch me on the bootleg
cab podcast let's go
so why not 7am
I don't know bro uh I got that name from
Wiz actually that's a good name yeah bro
we were just in the studio one day or
one night one day or whatever you call
it it was actually six a.m so then I
kept repeating it in this song over and
over again he was just like bro as soon
as I walked out the booth he's like bro
you're six a.m right I just I I ran with
it since then yeah so before you were 6
a.m yeah you were in a group called osbs
I still am in a group called osps we're
just you know
doing your own taking a little shout out
to fizzy break for a little bit hell
yeah shout out feeding my brother so
osbs obviously you guys have some dope
records you went on tour with uh was it
Doug uh a Gunner and and whiz yeah
um
what and and the music you guys are
making was a lot more different in the
music you're currently making oh for
sure uh
I felt like the music that we were
making was uh
it was like
Dope music you know what I mean but I
think the I think that
the main thing between then and now is
just me like not knowing myself as an
artist I'm not like trying to like just
like make a song I'm just making songs
that I like you know I mean like I'm
making songs more organic yeah it's
geared towards me I'm not really trying
to be like I'm not I'm not I don't
really I don't want to talk about the
same things yeah yeah you know how it is
when you when you when you first start
out you know what I mean like I was kind
of trying to like
find myself and then like try to find
who I was as an artist after that you
know what I mean right so like it kind
of took a while for me to be like okay I
don't want to talk about cars I don't
want to talk about
um money like that I want to talk about
hidden licks and sliding just like
I don't know it just wasn't like
it
wasn't
it wasn't the same for me after a while
right I think we are on on tour and like
Denver or something honestly and I took
[ __ ] DMT
and like once I took that
the DNT it was like a whole switch like
and my whole body just changed like
instantly and I just like saw things
way differently like almost instantly
but it was [ __ ] crazy well DMT is a
serious uh psychedelic oh yeah it's like
so you smoke Aaron Rodgers drug yeah did
you smoke it yeah I did Freebase uh no
we smoked it out of a [ __ ] Apple
actually you smoke DMT out of an apple
yeah we smoked DMT I have an apple it
was like it was hella weird I can't
imagine that's the best way to smoke it
no I don't think it is but like uh I
don't know how to even like
it's like it's like a a white kind of
like it's like substance which I don't
[ __ ] with you know I mean yeah it looks
like some and then the way you're
actually supposed to smoke it is you're
supposed to freebase it yeah that's I'm
not with that [ __ ] you know I mean
that's how you're like oh I know but
you're like give me the Apple yeah
that's chill so
basically what we did is put like weed
on the bottom and put like a layer of
like DNT in the middle like a little
like a hamburger you know what I mean
then you put like a layer of weed on top
so you use the wheat on top to like burn
through to the DMT so you're not
actually going to touch the fire to like
the the yeah it sounds like tea you know
what I mean yeah it sounds like you
should try to smoke DMT again no so it's
crackhead away well I did like 80 times
that's why I'm like this now you know
what I mean so like have you smoked it
the right way yet yes I have so you have
no that's not the right way I wouldn't
consider that the right what do you
think is the right way
uh I think out of a a wood pipe is the
correct way to to do it from what I've
heard I've never heard anybody even
talking about like freebasing freebasing
anything until you right now we have
Freebase of DMT man you get the [ __ ]
I'm not a big you're not a tour
you're supposed to smoke it out of a
crack pipe get the [ __ ] out of here bro
for sure
Kev where did you hear this from
everybody in my entire life that does it
they smoke it out of a crack pipe
because it's the most purest way to hit
it
I'm being serious I don't know about
that bro honestly when you have you have
like the actual toad sweat or whatever
from the [ __ ] frog right and it's
like yeah yeah yeah so that [ __ ] you're
supposed to actually I've never smoked
that I've only smoked like the like the
what's it called the tree bark so tree
bark what's the craziest thing you've
seen on a DMT trip oh instantly bro like
the first time I I did DMT it was me
fizzy and my cousin and then my cousin
did it first and he just like laid back
quietly and he just got absolutely quiet
and he went away for what 20 minutes or
so right no it's like two three minutes
and I'm like bro what the [ __ ] and he's
like
shh so me and uh feezy are both like
what the [ __ ] is going on and he like
comes out of it after like two or three
minutes and just like sits up and
there's tears coming down his face like
literally like there's just like two
little yeah two little tears just
dripping down the side of his face and
he's like bro like you don't understand
he's like he's like the aliens are here
and it's okay and I'm like what the [ __ ]
so you're like give me something no
instantly I'm like all right let me try
that so I hit it and honestly bro like
the whole room just got like quiet like
the whole room got quiet and I was still
100 present and like mentally in the in
the moment like I knew I had just hit
DMT right there was no high involved
like change whatsoever but like
it's like a unlocked and hold uh another
dimension I was still completely
sobering in my mind and able to
understand exactly what was going on
there was basically just like little
[ __ ] aliens popping out from behind
like
random ass shapes being like like we're
here but don't don't tell anybody type
[ __ ] I know this sounds absolutely
insane but it actually doesn't because I
mean if you I I mean it doesn't sound
that crazy it's pretty intense bro so
like is that the most intense though
because I've heard people like go away
[ __ ] no dude for 20 minutes 10 things in
the world is uh
I'm Salvia dude I mean no I mean like
for you it was at the most intense
experience you had on DMT oh yeah but
it's nothing compared to to salvio
whatsoever what the [ __ ] is that bro are
you serious right now
is salvia legal it's legal they they
sell that [ __ ] smoke shops like spice
dude it's the strongest [ __ ] thing
I've it's the worst possible experience
you can ever have bro like
I was 18 years old my first week of
college
uh I was on my homies like bunk bed he
had like a a bunk bed in this room there
was like a bunk for him like his like
a dog slept on top so right some [ __ ]
like that so then the dog's on top of
the bed and I [ __ ] hit this [ __ ] and
I'm looking into like a mirror in his
room
whole room turns into to uh to as soon
as I exhale the whole room turned into
like mirrors like a million of them what
I'm [ __ ] stuck in this room locked in
it's like an over
overwhelming like Dread [ __ ] feeling
and I stand up as fast as I can to try
to escape and all of a sudden I just
feel something warm like dripping down
my head bro and I'm like what the [ __ ] I
snapped at it after like two minutes and
my homie's like bro what the [ __ ] you
okay you okay I look I look bro and
there's [ __ ] like blood dripping down
from my eyebrow onto my head from where
I split my [ __ ] head open on the bus
from the from the Salvia dude some [ __ ]
I bought from like a smoke shop like 20
bucks Jesus Christ oh my God worse than
worst worse than DMT like change your
life for the positive it did honestly
bro you remember how it was before you
know right you know me bro I was I was a
little uh
I was a little harsh bro I was a little
like you're definitely on your ignorant
gangster [ __ ] yeah a little bit bro and
I feel like the
DMT and just like life experience like
having my kid and [ __ ] kind of like took
me to a whole different place where I
was like aware of the energy I'm putting
into the world and aware of the energy
I'm putting into my music you know I
mean and like I don't I don't really
want to influence people to be out here
and living in the way they're not
supposed to be you know what I mean and
like affect the music that I make now
kind of either like teaches people to
deal with like certain things that
they're like right going through helps
people like understand certain like
emotions or feelings that they might be
having and it just kind of puts me in a
different place like karmically you know
what I mean like for sure I feel like
I'm such a [ __ ] like a drain on the
energy of the world which I feel like a
lot of of music that I even had to stop
listening to like that just because the
[ __ ] like negative it's a lot of
nativity too yeah bro like it's like if
you listen to something over and over
again in your subconsciously it sticks
subconsciously that [ __ ] is all in your
head bro like even whether you recognize
it or not it's just not for me no more
bro yeah obviously coming from your
background
um and you obviously have a special like
uh perspective on
La for sure
what is like I know LA's always been
crazy but I feel like it gets publicized
more and more now right because we
always see oh yeah because it's
Instagram and [ __ ] Tick Tock and you
see in all types but you think it has
gotten more intense since like the EDD
ship dried up for sure well uh
let me put it like this Ed put a lot of
money in hands of people that weren't
used to having a lot of money you know
right and they and a lot of people
started Living a certain lifestyle that
maybe didn't put in the work to live
that lifestyle and grew accustomed to
going to eat at wherever they want right
Bossa Nova you know what I mean certain
people grew accustomed to living a
lifestyle and portraying a certain image
that they maybe didn't know how to how
to maintain you know what I mean and so
when you live in
and what was there like eight a million
people in in the city right and I'm sure
like six million of those eight million
are
close to the poverty poverty line or
under it you know what I mean and when
you highly
publicizing what you'd be wearing and
jewelry and posting your location and
you know what I'm saying like not trying
to say anybody did certain things but
but uh all of that kind of
draws in a certain type of
the viewership you know what I mean and
uh when people are looking at you uh
flexing all day yeah and doing this and
that and you in their city and these
this person you're struggling this
person got the
baby mama hitting them up like hey man
what's up with this child support or
what's up with this or they might not
have enough to pay rent it's easy for
somebody in in in in in our city to be
like man who on Instagram right now who
who over here
who's outside exactly bro like bro you
know there's like 20 spots in L.A that
people are actually at well you're up
for yeah always like if you just hang
out in front of certain restaurants
you're like yo you if you really wanted
to get hit a lick walking out everything
you know that you know that and there's
and I I hate to say it but
people need to
value themselves more than they value
their image you know I mean like yeah
like there's a certain like there's a
certain way people like to move now
because of Instagram and
social media and all that [ __ ] and like
you might get ahead in the uh terms you
might get them some more some followers
or something like that but you putting
yourself on a whole you like yeah
because when when you leave you're me
you're dressed for everyone else you're
not dressed for yourself exactly you're
trying to impress everybody yeah you
know but I used to fall
victim to that as well you know I mean
like and I used to to worry about like
damn if I if I if I show up over here to
go go do this show I got to have 12 12
[ __ ] with me and this and that
because I because I because I have on
this chain I got on this watch and I
want to make sure that I protect my own
investment right bro you see now bro I
don't got no jury on no nothing bro like
so if you got an issue with me you just
[ __ ] then you know what I mean like I
don't got anything you could
possibly want like
yeah anything like that I ain't carrying
around no stack like all my cash is in
my car on my account you know what I
mean like that's bad it's unnecessary
it's all ego it's not just that because
I've been on the other side of it before
and I know how easy it is to to to to
First somebody out here to really be
like Oh I'm attract this [ __ ]
down like bro I know how easy it is I
mean people throw the air tags on your
car like not even that bro like it's
really a very simple thing to do like
bro if you post if somebody else post on
like a flyer or something like this
person's performing at this time at this
place or they showing up to this event
or they showing up at this club bro it's
so easy like come on bro like if you
want to find anybody in La that's
actually out actively
I'm working you can get it done it's not
that I think like a lot of it too is
like
because a lot of security guards are
affiliated right do you think a lot of
times like those guys are giving like
tipping people off or is it usually
I couldn't I don't want to put that on
the security guards like that bro
because it's really just people being
idiots or bro like if true if people are
out in in in in in La like but let's
just say like you like bowling or
something right at pins
200 people then already seen you at pins
and already told this person you can't
really say it everybody goes depends
that's what I'm saying like come on bro
like 200 people like people put
themselves in a situation where they
have to defend their life over over a
watch
there's a time and a place for
everything you know what I mean there's
a tiny place or anything you don't need
to have that [ __ ] around bro if if the
uh jewelry is what makes you you then
you ain't [ __ ] hey we gotta stop the
interview real quick you already know
man our partners in my bookie they be
holding me down when it comes to all the
money I'll be making on gambling on
these [ __ ] Sports man that's
right they're your sports betting Haven
all right and it is Thanksgiving week
big games coming up uh yo we got the uh
Cowboys obviously playing the Giants
Vikings versus the Patriots Bills vs
Lions I think the bills are going to
absolutely
destroy the Lions uh actually you know
you could put together a nice little
three team parlay on thing Thanksgiving
so while you're watching turkey you can
watch some football and you can win some
[ __ ] money all right but this is the
most important part when you go to my
bookie go to my bookie right now
mybookie.ag
sign up for a new account use the promo
code bootleg
and guess what they will match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
so let's say Thanksgiving you're like
you know what I'm trying to get in on
some of this action that's cool sign up
at my bookie put in two three hundred
dollars they're gonna give you another
two or three hundred dollars of free
money to gamble with if you use the
promo code bootleg all right mybookie.ag
head over there right now sign up for an
account so much to gamble on right now
we got NFL we got NBA baseball's over
baseball's trash who gives a [ __ ] NFL
NBA and I think hockey's going on
college football is going on college
basketball is going on what are we
[ __ ] doing let's get this money
mybookie.ag go sign up use the promo
code bootleg right now and they will
match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars let's get back to the
interview how are you you ain't [ __ ]
anyway yeah I heard somebody say that
recently it's like if you took away what
you're best at right
should start thinking about that like if
you like look at yourself you say yo my
whole life revolves around what I do the
best whatever that is whether you're a
rapper you're a musician oh for sure
maybe you're a video director whatever
it is what happens if you take that away
who are you exactly who if you know what
I mean exactly bro it has to be like I
don't know I feel like everybody just
needs to
really just be
self-aware more than anything yeah be
self-aware bro if if if you look like
food you're gonna get ate take yourself
off that plate don't don't give nobody
opportunity to even or move around feel
me like you gotta move or move right bro
yeah move right you know what I'm saying
like some people some people need to
check in bro like some people need to
check in and and know how to move around
not on some [ __ ] like oh let me check in
because I'm scared
yeah let me check in so so I can have
the lay of the land that people right
paying attention to me and telling me Oh
don't go over here or don't go over here
it's not cool like that like bro like
even like uh pnb my boy bro like yeah
that was wrong oh he was a great guy a
good good good dude bro like super here
dude me and him weren't super close but
we was cool bro like every time we met
it was always 100 respect he wasn't one
of them Hollywood dudes to act like they
don't know who you are after you just
met last week you feel me like he was a
solid dude bro and I wish he would have
been with anybody that would have been
like bro don't go over there you know I
don't go over there bro I don't go over
there I don't know anybody even though
you know me I don't go over there bro
come on bro yeah like that's not it bro
yeah it's it's interesting too because
he had been here so long and been around
and you know he's been around the right
people at times and it's like you would
just think he would know that yeah I'm
out the way bro yeah you know what I
mean so you mentioned checking in for
people who don't know I got put on to
you because big you signed you guys yeah
um shout out shout out to Big you great
guy
um somebody who's been a big homie to me
for [ __ ] almost 10 years now
um and you know what's dope about big
you is like I've never had him really
ask me for anything bro don't ask
somebody for [ __ ] does that make sense I
think people have this this
misconception about big you like bro
that's what
that's you just hit that on the head
right now people got the
biggest misconception about him like
that's probably the only person that can
go like
joke for a joke with me like if I sit
down with with big you think you joke we
can roast bro for an hour and he won't
stop like big you is really that type of
of human but everyone got the wrong
perception thinking that he was like
this guy had me [ __ ] bricks I'm at
um berries yeah and uh it's like three
in the morning
and I'm wearing a Texas Rangers hat oh I
already know where this story going so
listen somewhere in the Texas Rangers
hat it's me and Brian Sampson my manager
of the fat old Filipino man
and uh I get a text and
it's like
actually just read it because I still I
have to still have it because it wasn't
that long ago
this was not that long ago and you know
big Hughes got my Android number
nobody's got this number unless you've
known me forever
[ __ ] was I was I was like what the [ __ ]
where is it at here I already know where
this is going okay here it is
[Music]
um
he hits me up okay it's 1 30 in the
morning yeah I'm at I'm eating right bro
West up I'm like what's up man you good
he's like nothing I've been trying to
reach you I said I'm here always what's
the word I haven't seen any missed calls
I'm here with Brian Sampson he said I've
been trying to reach cuss also tell cuz
y'all need to pull up on a face to face
I'm like what the [ __ ]
I was like uh everything good and he put
issues dot dot dot I said what happened
I could call you now he's like man we
family pull up tonight
and now I lie to him oh yeah for sure I
say where at I'm all the way in Valencia
so I tell them I'm in Valencia right no
no he said why you got that t-hat on
though
don't say that kid that's what I stood
up
I said where is this [ __ ] at and
he stood up he was dying oh he got you I
said God damn man you had me lying to
you bro he said you had a two yet what's
up with a hat I'm like bro I don't
[ __ ] know it's blue and I like it
oh it's a good hat
[ __ ] damn it's a bad hat to wear right
no for sure yeah so great guy though but
how did you guys uh how did he find
y'all uh I know for a while
um his
his kid his son his oldest Lil you is
like
my best friend and then his nephew
ephesia is like my other best friend so
in other words you've have you spent
some wild nights at Molly old house
that's legendary huh bro when I was
coming out here doing weekends I would
sleep there bro I remember never mind I
remember that we had a crazy night take
an elevator we had like a we had like a
fight outside the house with like some
crazy dude
bro there was like eight dreads on the
floor the next morning we woke up at
Molly Mall's house me and fizzy walked
out we like damn what the [ __ ] is that
on the floor it was like eight dreads
would you were you all ever like staying
there because I feel like everybody I
stayed there for like a week at a time
for sure maybe you're like [ __ ] like
that I never could be there for too long
because you just didn't know what was
going to happen at that house ever like
bro like yeah that was like that [ __ ]
but it was actually should have been
recorded bro you feel me that's just
it's crazy because how his house was
here based on how his house used to be
in Vegas it's like the PO polar opposite
no exactly like his old house it was
like Fort Knox no for sure like you had
to know somebody to be in there yeah
they were I feel like when he moved to
LA I go like you said you'd go over
there and be like what kind of gangster
I had so many inscriptions little
situations bro I've had so many little
bro I've had times where I'm I'm in
there recording and I walk out the booth
it's like 20 people in the room after
I'm like but who the [ __ ] is this
everyone's driving this car everybody
extra down got Hood tests I'm like oh
what type of [ __ ] is this bro like and
I'm all just upstairs like it's okay
guys I'll be downstairs in a little he's
up there [ __ ] three girls at once
[ __ ] three insane bed you ever see
his bed bruh pause I mean but I've been
in this bedroom pause pause no homo yes
but his bed is like uh it's like it's
like six California Kings like stitched
together for sure yeah shout out to
Mommy my free money more free mob man
that's my brother man great guy that's a
crazy [ __ ] right yeah anyway so
you you uh met him uh you met big you
because you knew his son yeah okay you
know I mean like we basically all
all grew up together and uncle was
always with nip you know what I'm saying
so like to me like the only person I saw
that I knew that was like successful at
rap ever was knit you know what I'm
saying and I knew that Unk was the one
that did everything for nip the one that
got his career started one that did
everything for him so
in my mind from the time I was like in
high school I was like damn I need to be
on that type [ __ ] you know what I mean
so uh
to me has always been like P Diddy you
know what I'm saying like that's how we
see him in in our area you know what I'm
saying for sure we see UNC is like P
Diddy like he's the way out the hood and
I always knew that you know what I mean
like uncle's uncle is the way out yeah
you know what I mean so obviously you
and nips here from the same area yeah
um what is
yeah I feel like it's hard to kind of
like for people who aren't from LA to
like understand like how big of a loss
he was nip is like and then our Tupac
and I kind of I mean like and I love
Kobe right but I feel like
Kobe dying hit me really hard right it
was [ __ ] up it hit the world hard but
I feel like Nipsey dying hit La harder
oh bro that that was like Kobe's like
just lost we ever took ever as a city
him and Kobe I would say nip number one
and no for sure Kobe but I'm just saying
remember it's crazy because I I will be
number two because I cried on you could
cut it with a [ __ ] knife in L.A bro
Unk had people from hoods that
their certain hoods in L.A that don't be
around each other no matter what and I
try to trade carefully interviews
because I don't really like to say like
what hood is what and all that [ __ ]
because you know I you know uh but no I
mean he had that day where everybody
United bro that's what I'm that's what
I'm trying to say like bro it's been
there's hoods in La that don't be around
each other no matter what like it's
instant smoke you know I mean that UNC
had everybody all in one spot all
together
coming together for nip and that just
goes to show you how great nip is and
how great uncle is you know what I mean
because like those two right there bro
like
everybody you don't like everybody in
South Central
looked up to Nick no matter what where
are you from they don't matter where the
[ __ ] you from like even the people that
hated nip
end up happening end up having to be
like damn like that's that guy you feel
me like yeah at the the end of the day
and like nip just show all of us
in L.A that like man we all could do
this [ __ ] you know what I mean like we
all can do this [ __ ] and he he and it
was like
nip was just a whole whole different
energy than most people because like he
was just so
so intelligent right you know I mean and
when and when and when you get that like
a realness with that authenticity it's
like it's a whole different breed bro
and not many not many people can ever
hold a candle to nip in in
uh the LA no matter what just for sure
just off his [ __ ] impact overall to
everybody you know what I mean like
that's the goat man so if nipsey's
passing can bring that many people
together who would usually be on site
with how do you keep that energy going
does everyone just need to smoke DMT man
that's the problem bro like
because that's cool everyone that comes
together for a day but then what happens
like two weeks later or exactly right
six years later you know honestly we
just need people that are more like
Uncle Nick like you know I mean like we
need more people like that that can
really lead youth in a positive
different direction you know what I'm
saying like I hate to say it but you
know the little like what's some little
dudes names a little like uh a jungle
Stone whatever you know what I'm saying
maybe it's not gross whatever the [ __ ]
that is not it bro like that that that
type of energy that's the [ __ ] that that
hold us back you know what I mean and uh
I have to say like bro like like that
type of [ __ ] is
it needs to be redirected because
obviously like like a lot of these kids
got talent and all that but they putting
it in into the wrong [ __ ] you know I
mean yeah I mean I had them on come up
here and freestyle and they seem like
nice kids you know but I mean they're
kids though yeah but that's what I'm
saying there's like uh growth involved
in all that but I feel like we need like
more like OG's and like not even OG's
like G's like nip you feel me like more
people need to set an example in fact
this is what we trying to push man we
ain't on that type time like you know I
mean like more people have to speak up
and stop trying to be cool and just fit
in with everybody else and copy what
everybody else is doing and really just
like be like true to themselves and say
like hey this is the type of music that
we're doing like like the the the music
culture in
the LA has been changing a little bit
because the artists like
a blast and a Beano and [ __ ] like that
exactly like I feel like that's kind of
that's that's also helping you know what
I mean because it kind of a Roddy Rich
it kind of shares a Different Light two
even like some of the like like the one
take Jays of the world yeah exactly like
those guys are like not necessarily
letting politics get in the way exactly
that's what I'm saying and I feel like
the younger kids at least most I mean a
lot of the younger generation of La rap
they seem to be more united than I've
seen previous generations maybe because
they're not as a like heavily Affiliated
and then even the artists that are you
know like obviously there's artists that
don't [ __ ] with each I just saw the baby
Stone guy and the ASM bobster guy going
back and forth on Instagram like Jesus
Christ
um but yeah I just think that like you
said man it takes
you know
I think some some of it's generational
but you know I think it takes like those
homies like yeah that's really like it's
like you know uh I'm sure you got a guy
like Wiz who has put his arm around you
who probably has seen your whole
oh I ain't gonna lie bro you were
hanging out with him when you were on
some [ __ ] osbs I ain't gonna lie bro
that's that's that's my big brother I
can't give enough thanks to him for
really like bro where's like really like
took my
took my whole mindset and was like nah
bro like this is what you need to to be
on type [ __ ] right like for
for a while like I ain't gonna lie like
at first when he used to talk to my dad
like oh man like I know what I'm doing
type [ __ ] but then when I really like
listen it was him and like uh and Chevy
really yeah that like caused me to go
through this little like uh and I'd
already like went through a change as a
human but like with my with my music I
feel like they helped me be more
comfortable with just being like true to
myself right what I mean being more like
open and honest in my music and uh like
you can't you can't you can't trade that
mentorship and artists like development
for anything you know what I mean like
where's
executive produced my whole project with
me spent hundreds of hours on my [ __ ]
you know and you're on the new project
with him yeah
I got like three songs on there I got
two with me whiz and uh
MP fire I got one with uh me whiz and
Ty dollar sign too fire and uh it's just
like people like that
just even giving you a [ __ ]
opportunity right coming from what I
come from bro it's like that [ __ ] don't
happen you know what I mean yeah I think
uh a lot of people don't have that that
opportunity to have somebody like Wiz
and they're like to be like hey that's
what you should be doing yeah even not
just that like even just like calming me
down and like having me like on some
like a big bro like life [ __ ] like he
got me in the gym bro you remember I was
getting the hell of that for like two
years bro like my stuff the lean thing
no I ain't sibling since like well uh
when I went to the pen it was 2000
2013. hey we gotta stop the interview
man to tell you about our good Folks at
Blue chew baby that's right make sure
you go to bluetooth.com uh and use the
promo code bootleg yeah because what
happens at bluetooth.com is you get the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis but it's delivered right to your
door in a discreet package no doctor's
appointments involved fellas yo it's
getting cold as [ __ ] and you got that
dick you're trying to lay on a lovely
lady consensually of course all right
you might as well make sure you show up
to the party with all the [ __ ]
HGH uh you know uh performance enhancing
uh situations you could have you really
just need to pop a single blue shoe and
you're [ __ ] out there man you're
gonna have the hardest [ __ ] you've ever
had in your life alright so listen go to
Bluetooth
and uh use the promo code bootleg
because you get your first month for
free so go to bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg you get a whole month for free
try it out
okay try it out with that promo code
bootleg and don't forget they just
dropped their mint flavored chewable
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra that's right so that means it's
a little bit more pep in your step you
go to the mint you go the old school
Bluetooth whatever it is you're gonna be
[ __ ] bud for sure you're gonna wake
up in the morning with the hardest [ __ ]
you've ever had in your life all right
I promise that's Cyrus he just takes him
and jerks off in his bedroom
he's got Bluetooth Fridays at his house
everyone's out there working Cyrus the
producer he eats a blue Chute he turns
the surround sound on he's got the
[ __ ] PornHub going and he's just
beating his dick like it stole something
anyway bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
and you get a free month of blue chew
right now going to sign up and [ __ ]
help us out because you know what I'm
saying we trying to get this money too
all right bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg let's get back to the interview
and I and I came down Sick off like how
old were you uh or how long ago or I was
20 when I went to jail and I was 25
four when I got out so you did four
years yeah in the state pen yeah [ __ ]
what was your if you don't mind me
asking uh I got charged with three
attempted murders and two armed
robberies when I when I uh first got
arrested it was only one attempt and one
armed robbery and they added two more
attempts in the armed robbery so I end
up uh beating all the attempted murders
they end up finding like camera footage
from across the street like six months
after right that that proved I didn't do
[ __ ] when it came to that so I ended up
uh beating the attempts and uh ended up
getting one arm armed robbery and I'm
assuming that wasn't your first time you
ever got in trouble with the law I got
in trouble for the same exact [ __ ] I had
an open case for that the same exact
[ __ ] I had an open case for uh robbery
before that when you were had you been
20 years old in La you might be over on
Sunset for [ __ ] shaking some pools
down as well
I don't know you know I don't know bro I
I just I feel like uh that
that really like helped get my mental
right more than anything like I just
said I had to do it in four years
because I've I found a [ __ ] like it's
in meditation book it's like a [ __ ]
Phil Jackson book I swear to God I just
picked it up on the on the yard one day
and I just like I was into it that's why
I got the Buddha on my neck yeah the
home and [ __ ] because I it just took me
on like a different place mentally you
know what I mean I was like man like
this is what I need like I need
something to calm me the [ __ ] down so
something about like the Zen like a
Buddhist right culture resonated with
you brought me in I needed it
um you're racially ambiguous yeah what
is your what's your break it down man
bro I swear to God bro so uh people
always assume I'm like
Puerto Rican or like a Mexican off the
bat right I'm I'm Creole bro I'm like
black white French Indian you feel me
like I always figured you were like
Mexican a little bit of Brazilian in
there you know what I mean a little bit
but but
really like that's really why I'm like
this too like my whole life like you
feel me from the time I was born I was
never black enough for the bright black
kids to accept me and I was like too
black for the
you know what I mean so it kind of left
me in like a weird place and I had to
kind of be more extra out than you
should be to to be
accepted by by who I wanted to be
accepted by you know what I mean so I
had to be up look if you if you ever see
this is the truest [ __ ] ever
if you ever see a a group of hood [ __ ]
in the whitest one in the group is
probably crazy as [ __ ] bro like let me
just would you say you were the craziest
one in your group
I had quick reaction times that's all
I'm gonna say yeah I had quick reactions
I respond to things like instantly but
now you know I do MMA everything you've
definitely growing a lot I was gonna say
are you ever worried that like
um some old chicken yeah all the time
like all the time you're a new level in
life mentally all the time bro I always
think like damn like
because
I know people can hold a grudge for a
long [ __ ] time so I'm always just
Super Hyper aware of like of myself and
and my surroundings and everything like
that because
you know you'll never know like as I'm
saying like I'm pretty sure like my
Karma's like pretty even now after
everything you know I should be about
here now but uh you'll never know you
know what I mean so I'm always hyper
aware of my surroundings and like even
even when I meet people I have wrong
before I saw somebody
at a bar that I robbed in high school
and I was like damn bro like I'm sorry
bro like I'm not gonna you ain't gonna
get it back but I'm I feel terrible
about it you know I mean like man you
want to drink you know I mean like some
[ __ ] like that it happens he was with
like he was with like eight people and I
was like all by myself too [ __ ] I had
like one homie with me my homie was like
a five two like like Asian dude and he
didn't do nothing so I was like thank
God because he could have whooped my ass
right there now he had about eight
people with them I was like damn this is
gonna be oh bad I'm gonna be all over
the gram tonight Jesus he ain't do
nothing though but at the end of the day
like I do MMA every day
uh because like you know cap got me on
that type program I wake up every
morning I I go to the gym I do my my my
my uh MMA are you doing Muay Thai or
yeah two or more time I do like Muay
Thai and and boxing yeah but like
it just helps me keep my my mind
straight and also keeps my reaction time
on point so if I gotta hit somebody up
in the jaw and get the [ __ ] out of there
that's that's possible you know what I
mean and bro just that I'm Muay Thai
[ __ ] like
I ain't gonna lie like uh
I actually see like uh where's in there
every day I'm like damn this [ __ ] is
like a goddamn uh a ninja you feel like
I'm trying to get on that type time I
remember uh
Louise in the studio one night for like
a week we had already been in there for
a week and I went into the wrong uh
the studio
so we have been recording in like uh the
a room for like a week right this is
like the eighth ninth day in a row right
so we just hit me like hey bro come uh
come pull up so we get to work so I pull
up I walk in the wrong Studio there's
like eight security guards outside that
I ain't never seen before so I'm like
damn who the homie must have somebody up
in here like you know I'm thinking he
got like Wiz Kids somebody you know what
I'm saying so I walk up in I say what's
up to everybody I I grew up in there man
it's not weird it's [ __ ] uh Playboy
cardi oh [ __ ] bro I'll walk up in that
[ __ ] I'm like oh
[ __ ] my bad like I apologize like but we
we've been in here for a week like bro
you know I'm not trying so I'm like hey
bro I apologize bro I don't mean to come
interrupt interrupt your session your
session I'm looking for cap so I I bow
to him bro like you feel me like I I bow
to this man as I leave the room like as
a as a show like respect yeah about it
to oh boy bam my bad bro and get out
your way
so I walked out out the room I'm walking
back across to the uh the parking lot to
uh uh uh go to the studio I'm like oh
I'm in the wrong ones let me let me go
over there
sounds like it costs a lot bro and like
I'm probably like 15 yards out I'm
pulling out my phone to call Cap like
hey bro like uh where you at yeah you
feel me
out of nowhere I hear hey [ __ ] I'm like
what the [ __ ]
and I turned back it's [ __ ] Playboy
carty like running outside bro in the
blouse like he running outside like
and then behind him there's like six
more [ __ ] come out behind him and the
door opened again like six more [ __ ]
behind them bro so it's like 12.
13 [ __ ] outside when I look back in a
in a matter of like two seconds bro what
they think you stole something or
something I'm trying to figure it out
I'm just I'm just doing the same [ __ ]
you doing I'm like bro what the [ __ ]
going on here bro I I out of nowhere
he's like hey
I don't like weird ass [ __ ] coming up
in my studio
I'm like whoa cause bro I'm I'm really
like taking it back like what the [ __ ]
is going on bro so I'm like hey bro
chill I'm like bro chill out like bro I
walked in there with some humble [ __ ]
bro and and I told you bro I was in the
wrong lab like bro you should be asking
your security guards why the [ __ ] they
let a random ass [ __ ] walk in there's
all six of them up and up in your
session they don't even know me from a
can of paint right that's who you should
be mad at he like oh oh
so I'm like whoa I'm like [ __ ] what are
you doing bro I swear to Bro God strike
me down right now bro this [ __ ] say
um I said look bro we ain't gonna do all
that extra that [ __ ] because you know
and I told him where I was from you know
what I'm saying so I told him that he
was like what on pirodo and I said oh oh
no you feel me I told him where I was
from I'm good I know so he like because
it's like oh uh you know you like oh so
what's up then I'm like bro what you
trying to do I'm like I'm like bro I
squabble you and your whole Squad he
like oh I don't need no whole Squad I
scrub you all by myself I'm like oh this
[ __ ] turn I'm like bro he really crazy
like he don't see how it's called
Playboy carty yes bro look I don't even
know this name from a can of paint I
never met this man before you feel me
like we ain't had no interactions so I'm
really like it's my first interaction
with the [ __ ] ever right so I'm like
bro
you know this what it is he told me
where he was from again
so that's when at the point where I'm
like bro what's up what you trying to do
he tell me
I scrub you all by myself I don't need
nobody so I'm like come on in let's go
bro come on I pull up like this you know
hold on I got my little chain huh yeah
I'm pulled up
pull my pants up are you from La you
know what that mean when [ __ ] I pulled
a pants up he was sitting back there
talking to his boys like that I said man
shut the [ __ ] up you ain't talking about
nothing I was low-key spooked I thought
the [ __ ] about to whip my ass on the
way in as soon as I turned around yeah I
walked around the park and I said shut
the [ __ ] up walk back in a lot they
didn't say nothing
telling you bro well that makes
everything a lot more because right
before you got here Playboy Cardi's
artist was here and his Entourage was
here so you walked in and you were like
and then when they left you were like yo
Playboy card you don't [ __ ] with me bro
that's why I'm not thinking it's gonna
get cracking I'm like bro like that's
what I'm trying to tell you bro this is
the last time I see him so after all
this
I walk in the studio I tell Wiz I'm like
hey bro this [ __ ] Playboy Carter you
crazy as [ __ ] bro you just read this I
ran up on you like 12 [ __ ] they just
look these people trying to bang on you
being go outside and Ninja Kick the [ __ ]
out these [ __ ] I'm like let's go [ __ ]
like I've been training already at this
point we'll start laughing he started
laughing he like ha he like he like that
sound like that crazy ass [ __ ] that's
my dog I'm like oh man I'm like man in
fact Playboy cardi was set on pyro no no
I told him look I'm trying to tell this
story but I don't know that's his boy so
he really like like laughing though he
like bro like that's my little bro like
like he like that he's like he crazy
like that I'm like oh he really liked
that I'm thinking he just doing it for a
flex he's from Atlanta right I don't
know where he from that [ __ ] crazy
though apparently he's from Piru he can
he from Piru too but he can get the ones
wait wait car you can get the ones
believe that Playboy card can get the
ones
so quick hey hey what up y'all we gotta
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our folks at hardean Las Vegas
you see them right there you know I mean
shout out to hard D Man shout out to
everybody over there it's the uh illest
dispensary in the world number one they
got the craziest selection of weed
you'll ever go to when you're in Las
Vegas there's only one place to go
that's Hardy and you pull up you say hey
I heard about this place on the bootleg
cab podcast and they're gonna get you
hooked up with some [ __ ] weed all
right so go to Jardine Las Vegas right
now if you're in the city of uh sin or
you're going make sure you uh you know
put it put together a little hour off to
the side to make sure you go get your
nice [ __ ] Harding bag full of uh just
a premium weed all right and not only
that you got to shoot them a follow
Harding underscore Las Vegas I want to
shout them out though because Harding
smells the best the dispensary is just
it's not only the best dispensary in the
world it's the best smelling dispensary
in the world and look now the bootleg
kit podcast smells like Jardin because I
have the Jardine signature scent candle
you could have one too you could go to
[ __ ] Hardy in Las Vegas just saying
also make sure you follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas that is
important you have to follow them
because there's some [ __ ] accounts
out there we appreciate hard Dean when
you're in Vegas pull up go get you some
smoke go get you some edibles go get you
some [ __ ] carts whatever it is they
got it and they got it at the highest
quality it's the only place I'm smoking
from that's Hardy in Las Vegas let's get
back to the interview I wanted to ask
you something because this kind of
relates specifically to your background
and and where you may or may not be from
but
when you see the quando Rondo thing
happen oh and he talks about
like that's just so goofy bro disavows
the like pretty much oh man that's just
so goofy but we ain't gonna talk about
bro that's just so goofy bro but in
terms of like that kind of thing
happening right because he's obviously
not from here see I'll put it like this
bro that's that type of [ __ ] could be
the opposite of me you feel me like I
feel like the more extra doubt you is
and all that [ __ ] like I be looking at I
already knew knew from the start how his
heart was just by how he talked you know
I mean like I could tell from the top
like you had too much extras like
if you know you know bro you feel me you
you don't have to act like the hardest
[ __ ] in the room to be the hardest
[ __ ] in the room like a look at big you
he always got us smile on his face
smiled on his face happy all the time
for sure super nice generous to
everybody and ain't nobody about to test
Unk you feel me yeah so that's how I
kind of look at [ __ ] like I don't I
don't give no attention to no
because I'm sure you had been around him
before right
and so I may have but it's just like
it's just when it comes to [ __ ] like
that like I don't really
foreign
people like quando man
you just gotta let you gotta let a goofy
be a goofy you know what I mean man like
all that all that I don't like people
that uh that uh
that change who they are and what they
stand for too often you know what I mean
I don't trust that I don't trust that
ever
um also you're here one of the uh guys
who dived all the way in on Sports Cards
during the pandemic bro you want to open
up a box right now I got a 300 hobby box
I mean you can do a war right now let's
do it let's do it
well you brought me a Stefan Marbury
card that's autographed shout out to
Steph starbury
they got a statue of this man in China
yeah this is called a box War man what's
this mean hobby box it's like
300 350 around that but you could get a
card up to like 12 12 000 15 000 in here
this is an NBA prism hobby box that's uh
that's lamelo year and Anthony Edwards
year so you can get like a okay a silver
lamelo autograph Anthony Edwards or even
a Tyler Halliburton maybe I like Tyrese
Halliburton nice bro he's always and and
the sun's passed on him for [ __ ]
Jalen Smith
[ __ ] James Jones this is how we do
this
it's a box War right this means you're
gonna pick the left side or the right
side of the Box okay and all the packs
on that side is yours
so if I could pull a 12 000 card it's my
first I can't do nothing about it okay I
got the homies outside waiting on you
when you leave but that's about it of
course you did
all right Kev left side of the right
give me the left you [ __ ] now so
that's the side I was pretty good you
know I always pick the left man yeah I
knew that
keep it at the left side right yeah all
right those your packs even mine so you
you really only don't even like say the
cards that's in there unless it's
something big like unless it's like an
Anthony Edwards like a lamello okay if
not just keep it going because who gives
a [ __ ] about a a smoosh Parker okay all
right all right all right all right so
but if it's like a LeBron or like a Luca
or something I tell you yeah for sure
okay
but this rookie year right here is
Anthony Edwards and lamella
I go through mine kind of quick though I
go to I look for the rookies I didn't
get [ __ ] there's a there's a shy but
it's a hollow SGA okay I didn't get [ __ ]
either I got Tim Duncan next pack what's
up with Ted Duncan still having cards
box Wars bro I ain't gonna lie I was in
a
oh 1500 clay a little while ago Aaron
Gordon magic Darius Garland
that's not a Garland rookie card is it
no his his rookie year before 19. yeah a
year before yeah
you looking for oh I got a
silver rookie but it's Daniel Arturo
that's probably only worth like twenty
dollars nobody gave a [ __ ] about that
oh I got a Devin Booker card
I don't know about you hey man let me
just have it for me I'm gonna put that
in my house somewhere let's go Aaron
Nesmith
oh yeah my bad bro
I ain't get [ __ ] so far bro you get
anything I got Devin Booker I got Kobe
white oh no he didn't get nothing
yeah I got the knees myth Miles Turner
yes this ain't it
uh oh
Patrick Williams nah that's my best card
though so far it's the Patrick Williams
rookie we ain't doing too good with this
box kid nope Jeff T Joshua yeah this is
trash Kendrick none that's what I'm
saying like there's sometimes you open a
300 guys [ __ ] zero you get zero
dollars back bro all right let's see
I got it quickly on the back
I got it quickly that's not a bad one
yeah
Anthony Edwards let me see that's an
emergent that's not a great one it's
probably worth like 20 or something like
that I should have asked Napier Jesus
Killian Haze that might be the best card
though so far oh I got a Tyrese maxi
that's a good one so this is how you do
a box where you you take my best card
and your best card I gotta get evaluate
this is worth nothing because who the
[ __ ] is Tyrell Terry yeah exactly uh
it's a rookie like who knows what he
might I gotta I got an SGA
Guinea of Egypt Dirk Nowitzki Devin
Booker who book
the book
come on man it's all bad we ain't
getting [ __ ] so far Rudy gobert Dwight
Howard
it's a really bad box bro
we ain't got one Edwards one lamella oh
I got a silver LeBron Hollow this is the
best car so far
uh the Kobe tribute dunk so how much is
that worth probably like 100 something
oh
I got a CJ McCollum that's red does that
matter
it's a if it was a good rookie it would
matter
no one's buying CJ McCollum cars CJ
McCullough may buy in CJ McCollum damn I
got an autograph
Xavier Tillman from the Grizzlies I
thought it was look at you looks like
you got the right [ __ ] side it looks
like I got the right side man
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our family at odd sucks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview
DeMar DeRozan
the LeBron's the one though last pack
man trying to get something good now I
got a horrible box I got an orange uh
orange Chris Paul and uh is Desmond Bane
was that his rookie year now that is a
rookie Desmond that's a good one I'm
gonna let you keep all these though kid
because I didn't I didn't I didn't I
didn't get what I was looking for
the kids going the kids gonna [ __ ] with
these
you're gonna let me keep that LeBron
card yeah you're a sweetheart oh I got
an AI I know that don't matter uh
okay now this is a rookie card it's an
Isaac okoro high impact yeah that was
that was a this this this box was not it
it'd be like that bro oh I got one more
pack left okay let me ask you this
what's the most expensive card you have
um
most expensive card I have I got like a
Herbert RPA that's worth about like 10K
something like that Justin Herbert yeah
I got an RPA worth about 10K but I got
would you invest in it though like what
was your buy-in on it uh I bought it on
a break I only put in like 80 bucks
really yeah I end up getting that
Herbert card it's like a break but the
chances are so [ __ ] small so what is
your um card collection worth
were you trying to get me robbed or
something you trying to get my house I
mean you just said you had a ten
thousand dollar card at that that's
enough reason to rob you alone yeah we
ate fish we hate to talk about off of uh
I would say
I would say my [ __ ] is
in the six figures but it's uh it's in a
a safety deposit box though most of them
so y'all y'all y'all stay the [ __ ] out
my [ __ ] well have you noticed like the
card Market go down a little bit for
sure because it was like so hot the car
market took a huge dip because uh Panini
and top started over satch reducing
their card to keep up with the market
and that's you still have your plug that
you follow on target oh this is crazy
Kev knows about this I used to have this
dude at uh Walmart and Target that would
tell me when everything restocked and
would hide it all in a certain part of
the store like like the diaper section
wow and there'd be like a hundred people
like going straight for the cards and I
go right for the diaper section and
check out with everything wow it'd be
hella [ __ ] pissed every time that's
crazy I probably I'm not gonna lie bro
over the over the uh
pandemic I probably made close to one
150 like one 160 just flipping cards
yeah that's dope but it it's like this
bro like if
if you buy the whole
thing from the whole store it probably
comes with like 40 boxes you might spend
like
a thousand bucks I would take that same
that same 40 boxes I keep like four of
them and I would sell uh the boxes
wholesale sell the rest of them for like
a a a a a 50 box I was getting paid like
180 200. I was just flipping the boxes
unopened yeah so I would make like
five thousand in a day as opposed to
like the gamble of opening the car yeah
I just I would like bro you saw what
just happened yeah we if we would have
went and sold that box right now we'd
have got like
300 bucks in fact you know we opened it
now you probably got like 100 bucks
worth of cars if that you know how those
College cards yeah the rookie class
cards so I bought a box because I
thought I was doing something I think I
hit you about it when I bought it which
one the the it was the I think it was
the draft picks draft picks I told you
don't buy those so I bought the Box
and no I bought like seven of them
and I opened all of them did this [ __ ]
huh no I got a bunch of [ __ ] but I got
like Anthony Edwards and but they're all
the they're the I feel like I feel like
oh yeah those aren't those aren't it's
worth as much aren't worth as much for
sure yeah that's crazy so like bro I've
seen people open to 20
000 like top of the line box and get
like 800 bucks worth of cards back if
not you could have sold that box for
lost 20 cages I'll open in a box but
that's the thing though like in this box
it could have been a 15
000 car like it happens you know what I
mean wow it just it didn't happen to us
yeah it didn't happen to us we're just
not cool enough bro
um Zombieland is the name of your [ __ ]
yeah that's the that's the name of my
first album that I've been like talking
about for like six months you've been
putting out singles so what is the
project coming up uh the project is
probably going to be out sometime around
the uh
first
week of January something like that so
it's done yeah it's all done I'm just
trying to clean everything up try to get
some [ __ ] cleared you know yeah a little
like process on that thing I I just
found that like
absolutely taking my time with
everything is just so much of a
of a better way to operate than trying
to like Rush myself or put something out
that's not a hundred percent the way I
do the way I want it I feel like when
you're like 200 Hands-On and [ __ ] is
just like so much easier boom well look
man I appreciate you pulling up and we
got to open some cards hell yeah go uh
stream this guy's music 6 A.M
what's the IG
call me 6 a.m at call me 6 a.m G Rage
with whiz is out you got three tracks on
there you got the right record going
crazy you got a couple music videos out
go run it up 6 a.m yes sir boom